house go Ambrose - vampire today we're
gonna play a game made by what what what
what what
apparently my relatives made this game I
thought it was made by a Swedish guy uh
but that's funny it's an adventure game
we haven't done one of those in a while
hi-hi keep watching it hasn't even
started yet
all right oh you can pause by a spacer
every I so this game has have been
getting a lot of praise it's a
Kickstarter and you have this
Warcraft 3 looking hand I love it
the demo while fully playable is in
alpha state let's just acknowledge that
for a second and let's play it oh god
how did this open I just wanted to play
solitaire so this is the difficulty I
have no idea what an adventure game even
is for experience so it's either these
two or like experience I'm pretty
experienced with the adventure games I
played a few but I'm not good with
pressure so don't judge me it's supposed
to be funny this game I think it's funny
alrighty so nice that's a good sign
oh this is retro this is an archive
infomercial and it's not to be used okay
joopa genetics that's my favorite
company now but as a logo
any company that has a but as a logo
Amaya fan of all that looks attractive
hello
is your child a failure yes if they
wasted years of their life acquiring the
art degree how do you make it rain on a
regular basis I do make it rain only to
spend it on your heels expensive taste
in [ __ ] coffee is goddamn right just
an [ __ ] these are questions we ask
every day treats it
Preeti hallelujah for genetics we have
the solution I'm what are you gonna do
prodigy child the fully customizable
child of your dreams
okay the process is very simple tell me
more we gather your broken dreams I'll
combine it with our cutting-edge genetic
sequencing technology and finally our
secret sauce then your prodigy child is
born okay don't leave your child's
success to chance they can be a prodigy
child in anything really jazz scientist
no way bodybuilder that is some nice
name lizard NAND cat okay now you're
just being ridiculous - do you really
want to risk the embarrassment my a
prodigy child today you won't regret it
uh is that him - put on some pizzas Oh B
C's it's all really the song really
reflects my soul and here we are
wonderful and I am so bored
what an amazing intern should make
progress on my EP and make some beats on
the computer so we're gonna
procrastinate which would never lead me
to relate my life decisions and leave
silently it's game it's like a simulator
of me hover over objects in their
description will appear okay
I knew that to interact with an object
congratulations you are now slightly
better at adventure games Thanks
he doesn't seem to be working just like
the combination of socks sandals and
fanny packs unless your faulty old man
packet sees the buns I should talk to
John probably would know how to fix it
damn it all my jokes only consistent
pants that's a kind of interesting
character I like his hairdo right very
attractive so he's like a failed oh okay
ah pick up probably should've washed it
but I just don't take up the how to kill
the little civilization of bacteria and
they're so cute I think they just hit
the bronze which I feel like these are
like butt implants placed in the wrong
way I mean look at that how is that not
a button alright get rich what is this
there we go alright which one should we
pick get rich or die of vegetable cosmas
ha ha babe I love you but I'm a t-rex
uh-huh that's a classic
Shawn sensual steen a guide to compute
companionship to Futuristics for the
futuristic lover this reminds me of that
movie her
if only I was gonna but if you were a
square I love all your four sides that's
I think III think this one just could
get children we got we got the the John
in the mood is ID his name is a big
computer ok let's exit from here we got
one of the records let's go to our EP
and do some sweet mixing inventory I
want it I thought you said if I Hubbard
my inventory would show what that fukk
was helpful is I remembered seriously
I'm not think too hard
how let her seem to magically appear
when I press this button god damn it I
really need to know how do you statement
or I was like oh that's so smart they
put another tutorial for people who are
stupid like me
please help I'm stuck in this in a
computer please
my god it's gave you hilarious seven
hours a reasonable sleep ads that's
enough sleep right but what do I know
I'm an omniscient narrator go look it up
on Google or something written adventure
get weird
don't break the fourth wall please it
freaks me out arises please look my EP
be the fastest of the Mon okay so he
wants to be a disco EP there has to be
some way to fix this
oh the cable is employed in alright well
there you go no it's [ __ ] oh thanks
oh Jesus what was I am it it is plug
from now to span to the public occasion
I need some sort of adapter okay alright
oh there it is all right indent restarts
through the letter I the letter I can be
found on most English keyboard oh my god
you're right see a local doctor to check
if you have a mental disability oh
thanks appreciate that so that's how you
do it thanks tutorial this game this
game man this game all right so how do
we yeah we have the adapter so we'll
kill Oh it'd be able to talk to our
adapter hello it did can I talk to
everything hello record there was no
sound though but it's an alpha so I'll
forget I am the adapter okay I came just
click on it there we go oh my would you
[ __ ] me full you know why you know
hahaha what the [ __ ]
alright oh god I'm so attractive
seriously I really like what you did did
to your face what's different quick you
did to your face what's different well
originally it was a picture of a big
fella objectively small advice on it I
have you to thank for that
why is my computer running here the
building I want to make some fat ass
pizzas my with some of the feel for
senior engineers tree almost surprised
mark speak on the boy if I want to be
part of this world so you don't think
about all the shields will be gutted and
they know
come on realtalk wise' not working why
is it not working mine the operating
system is bugging you gonna need a ward
and reinstall using the recovery 4p disk
okay
can't I just turn it on and oh yeah what
if you learn advanced IT support I'm
impressed
just like congratulations Drobo amazing
don't bother
alright they get it where can they find
the recovery floppy disk or all such a
mall little googly up and check it out
that's weird
it only tells me where to find 60
singles in my area but one little weird
secret to get ripped I've always
wondered what I'll look like of a
six-pack that face is a proper proper
reaction to that sentence just fill me
with all my oh yeah bald why you video
vixen computer soon to pay off I will
nail down to everyone we did own air we
might see life in Coulson acne within a
300 kilometer radius cheers my cheese
madness room I can give him please help
ah okay we need to figure this out then
uh there's a we need a desk or something
a real computer nice bite McGarrett
anyone gonna slice Oh miniseries you
know anyway you could warn the four
beauties from a fellow named space cadet
okay wannabe Ewan crush says here is
your drug addict hit fun with that
oh that sounds fun the world I guess 300
kilometers radius of it so that means we
can go my song by the way yes now I can
go meanwhile convenient plot my oh yes
what is he doing that duck I want bring
me
yes we need we need I wish I had hair
easy of robot potato I think he's a
robot potato what oh man
the humor in this game is like a father
your unsatisfiable urge for candy made
me into this monstrosity
but don't worry your legacy will live on
okay all right let's keep playing
that's a dog that's cool talk to how do
you say a lively flea life
photosynthesis throw okay bro
do you mind dropping some fat pieces
he's a beet isn't it some love that be
teased okay oh oh yeah ever ever what
now so close your bounds advantage ban
ban ban speech how do I feel how does it
feel to be a vegetable for the rest of
your life feel to be a vegetable for the
rest of your life I'm actually disgusted
you'd make the joke but if you serious
it feels pretty nutritious and delicious
my testers peace bro peace blue like I
said Ashton they mix like all kind of
languages I don't even know what this
world is about but that's a mail box a
little box yellow reminder of online
shopping over yet it's my mailbox heal
love them I guess I'll put it in my
invent right so we got a mailbox from
the mailbox really I he'll always like I
guess I'll put it in ah yes I'm already
using it to keep the building from
exploding there used to be a co2 list to
get inside then the game designer he had
better things to redesign like poop
jokes well at least he had a priority
straight set straight fighting warrior
pugs a guy you're in the game except
you're nothing five bucks four beats he
gave it to me for free all right let's
talk to him some more do you know much
about this basic did hmm
I know he is the local drug is it good /
wake me ten to seven years old
uncomfortably apparent fetish for boxes
I guess it's him I don't really know
much about him really except he keeps
asking for drugs in exchange for his
boxes also also [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
excuse me while I drown myself in the
pool bleach
did you consider gel to the blow jobs if
I wasn't a drug in this I'd probably
consider it it gets awfully lonely up
here its face is the perfect reaction
zero list uh anytime I can find out what
I can find him well if you find me a map
or something I'll hook you up with the
deets okay there must be something with
this here take this
I would put a mailbox in the mailbox it
pisses me off what are you serious
what's in here I'm going to uninstall
the game hey you the bottle vodka
congratulations on your new baby son
bottle take okay
so I looked inside the mailbox and there
was another mailbox I wasn't recording
and I'm sorry let's use it I much prefer
it okay and inside it looks like there
this can be a map yeah this is a map all
right so press m to toggle map got it
all right well we have the map we can
show it to this beat because why dice
pull scuttle crush this work yes I think
that would work you can find him in the
bottom writing coach forest also one
last thing don't I surprised it is not
wearing pants
I'll be surprised if he doesn't not
offer me to give up [ __ ] this is all
I'm saying
so now where do I go okay so I can click
on the map to go to different nations it
dude
cool what was the place is it here
is that him that's a space cadet this
game is insane wait I'll just wait here
are now now if I go back and explore the
world using the map this area is too
under the belly thank you I want to
flame out alright well that was para
para para dig I can't say it definitely
check out the Kickstarter if you thought
this seemed interesting I'm gonna
support it so I think you both shoot as
well if you're interested thank you for
liking this video and watching this with
me I had a lot of fun playing I'm very
excited about this game really funny but
yeah that's all for me for now that's
always say awesome Rose Ralph used